There's of the year,
you know,
such as every quarter,
for a week where you're eating a plant based diet or you're restricting me,
you're basically giving your body a break from being in that constant anabolic
state.
And I think that the,
the carnivores diet causes a lot of people to miss out on some of those
elements.
And then if you look at the blood work of uh,
um,
you know,
that doctor who doesn't cry or die,
he publishes blood work online and I don't know what else is going on with them
from a health standpoint,
but,
but you know,
I had really high blood glucose and really low testosterone and some things that
suggest that it might not be healthy to eat just meat,
you know?
And,
and did you have any really low testosterone?
That's interesting.
It's like 200 to 300.
It was really low.
Like really low.
Yeah.
Diagnosable hypogonadism combined with uh,
uh,
you know,
almost like borderline diabetes.
It did.
Is it possible to do it after a workout?
Uh,
he does a lot of rowing show,
real high intense pressure testosterone.
That's significantly,
it would increase your HSC RP and your inflammatory markers,
right?
Which is why you never want to,
you never want to go to a doctor for a heart checkup after you've done a workout
cause they're going to tell you you're going to have a heart attack based on the
levels of HSC RP,
but you know that blood work is just one example and I don't want to pretend
like that.
One example you know,
is going to paint with a broad brush,
the entire carnivore diet phenomenon.
But I just,
I think that unrestricted protein intake,
an unrestricted meat intake probably has an accelerated aging effect on the body
and well,
here's the different doctor.
Ron Rosedale is a doc who has some good information on that.
He's got a good video online.
What's going on with this carnivore diet is there's no science behind it.
There's a lot of people that are giving it a shot and a lot of people are
finding good results.
But I find that people when they just change things,
there's a period of time where they say they feel great and I that is absolutely
100% of placebo effect.
It's the same thing as like a Vegan Diet.
You feel fantastic and named me,
well name me one population,
one blue zone that eats meat like and nothing else.
And there's,
there's actually very few centenarians who are purely Vegan for their entire
life because you can,
if you don't do it the right way,
build up fatty acid deficits,
amino acid deficits.
Korea is when you don't get vitamin B 12 a Dha,
but at least it's been studying screen on Vegans,
right?
You spend a lot of studies on vegans and we know that if you eat,
uh,
like e three live,
you know,
you,
oh you can,
you can supplement.
There's a lot of really smart vegans.
I mean there's guys like rich roll,
like they do things the right way,
right?
It's,
it's the ball jeans a lot easier to see the piece of meat.
It's very little to get some of the B 12 and some of the other amino acids
you're trying to free up by soaking and sprouting and fermenting,
which my wife does a lot of it,
but I watch her like she,
she's in the kitchen like three hours a day making vegetables bioavailable cause
you wanted to take her hours to make sourdough bread.
Do you know,
to actually make a bread where the gluten is pre digested and it's actually
healthy and the glycaemic index is lower.
She's not Vegan and she's just a rancher girl and she likes to do goats and
chickens and we eat meat.
But she,
she's very into like an ancestral preparation of vegetables deactivating a lot
of these,
these stressors that doctor Steven Gundry talks about.
And you know,
before we pockets,
we're talking about Tom Brady and how he does like a no night shade,
no tomato,
no potato,
you know,
and I'd rather eat those things,
but actually figured out a way to render them more digestible and friendlier to
the human body.
Yeah.
That's the other thing too,
when people talk about food that has protein in it,
um,
you know,
like Broccoli has so much protein,
true,
not really bioavailable.
That shit ton of Broccoli.
It's just not the same.
Your body doesn't absorb it the same way it does it grass fed,
rib eye steak.
Yeah.
Body absorbs that protein instantly.
He knows exactly what that is.
Yeah.
By the way,
there,
there was a study that just came out about stem cells.
They found that carnosine,
which you find in copious amounts in,
you know,
grass fed,
rib eye steak with blueberry extract,
enhanced your stem cell production.
I mean,
it was a hugely significant number.
I don't remember the exact percentage,
but,
but this combination of polyphenols and flavonols with meat is a good combo.
That's why when I did the Carnivore Diet,
not the cardboard,
I,
that's why I was,
when I was eating meat,
I was doing lots of salads.
I was doing lots of,
I had like wild blueberry extract powder.
I had these vegetable powders,
you know,
I was doing a lot of big salads for lunch,
flavonols,
polyphenols,
any of that.
Uh,
same thing with the high saturated fat diet.
A high saturated fat diet,
like the whole coconut oil thing is highly inflammatory in the absence of plant
polyphenols and flavonols,
which is why if you're doing a high fat ketotic diet,
it needs to be a plant rich,
high fat Ketonic Diet.
Otherwise things on those lines.
You can get a lot of your father,
I mean,
Avocados,
yes,
but I'm talking about more like you doing coconut oil and butter and you know,
your avocado chocolate pudding and all these things.
You know,
you're,
you're Kenogenic fat bombs and all these recipes that are out there,
but he got itas badge out,
eat a lot of plants.
Even in the animal kingdom,
you see animals when they rip up another animal,
like a carnivorous animal,
they're in the intestines and the reading.
A lot of the organs that are chock full of what grass plants or herbs,
whatever that omnivorous animal that the carnivorous animal is eating.
Predict exactly when you're talking about carnivorous diets,
the real issue that I have with it is there's almost no research other than Dr.
Baker doing those tests on himself.
Which according to you are not very promising.
I didn't,
I have some friends that are trying it.
Um,
my friend Jordan Peterson,
his daughter had some serious anti,
some serious,
um,
uh,
immune system issues,
autoimmune disorders,
and uh,
like to the point where she's had a,
she's,
I believe she's like 30,
31,
she had a hip replaced.
She's about to get one of her,
uh,
ankles replaced like serious arthritis,
real problems.
The only thing that's been able to clear that up,
his meat,
just a pure meat diet with some people,
but she might have some,
I wouldn't say the only thing,
allergic reaction to plants.
I mean there might be something,
I don't hurt the meat wasn't the medicine.
Probably the elimination of whatever.
She's what I'm saying.
She might have some sort of a,
a real serious problem of some sort of allergic reaction to some plants or to
gluten and maybe a bunch of different ways.
A lot of these diets are,
it's the elimination,
not the magic of just dating me,
but Sean Baker keeps going on and on about how meat heels and meet this and meet
that all carnivorous diet and you know all these people are trying it.
Like man,
it's got a lot of good stuff going for it.
But but restriction of plant matter,
in my opinion,
long term is not a good idea and eating meat all the time,
long term is not necessarily good idea and eating only plants with the absence
of some meat based protein is for a lot of populations.
Not that great of an idea.
Yeah.
Well that's the point is that for most people you're going to have to experiment
a little bit to figure out what works best for you.
And there are people that,
especially if you use ie three live and algae and get your beat 12 vitamins and
your fat soluble vitamins,
you can live off of Vegan Diet.
It can be done,
but you really have to be careful about it.
But then there's other people where they can't and,
and you really have to figure out what the fuck is going on with the whole
carnival thing to me is kind of tweaking me out because I just don't,
it's like they start talking about the,
the poisons and Fido toxins and all these things that are in plants that are bad
for you.
I'm like,
okay,
the issue with mild hormetic exercise bad for you.
Sunlight's bad for all that stuff cause I'm a medic stressor is that your body
responds to that in a positive way and show some of that.
Some of the rodents outside of Chernobyl are living longer from the radiation.
And I'm not saying like go,
go move your cabinet next to a nuclear disaster website.
But the idea is that so hormetic stressor,
mild amounts of Uva and UVB.